a three-day federal government shutdown
is over and Senate Democrats are being
blasted by left-wing groups for buckling
and taunted by President Trump the
president tweeted quote big win for
Republicans as Democrats cave on
shutdown after signing a short-term
spending bill that measure does not deal
with the daca program for nearly 700,000
undocumented immigrants Senate
Republicans promised a vote on daca by
next month Nancy Cordes is on Capitol
Hill with this story Nancy good morning
what a day really and well this show of
this shutdown may be over
gale lawmakers bought themselves just
two and a half weeks before the money is
set to run out again and while Democrats
did extract that promise from the
Senate's leader they got no such
guarantee from House Republicans meaning
they're facing nearly as much
uncertainty as before with back-to-back
boats to reopen the government a motion
to concur is agreed to
Congress crawled out of a hole it dug
itself this is not a moment to pat
ourselves on the back not even close we
very much need to heed the lessons of
what just happened here
what happened was a three-day partisan
standoff over something almost every
leader claims to want a bill protecting
young immigrants brought to the US
illegally as children the issue of
immigration the issue of the dreamers is
the civil rights issue of our time the
White House argued Democrats gained
little from their hardball strategy I
would say that those numbers are much
more in the president's favor than in
senator schumer's favor Democrats
claimed they succeeded by forcing GOP
leader Mitch McConnell to commit to a
vote on dreamer legislation for the
first time some of your fellow
progressives thought you should have
held out for more I think we got a good
deal connecticut's Richard Blumenthal
disagreed believes the dreamers
how in the coal potentially vulnerable
to mass deportations Jose Lopez is one
of those dreamers his parents brought
him here from Mexico when he was 2 the
time to act was now and I feel like they
lost that chance he now works as a
communications director for a non-profit
in LA my biggest fear is that is it's
been 17 years there's gonna be another
17 years before we hear anything else it
all depends on how far four
congressional leaders can get in the
next 16 days crafting a compromise that
pairs dreamer protections with more
border security
I pray that neither I nor the Congress
will be in this same position come
February 8th he may need those prayers
because 16 legislative days well that's
really six days around here because the
house is taking the rest of the week off
that's a very short amount of time to
tackle an issue immigration that has
stymied Congress for decades one bright
spot in this spending bill for both
sides but really for Democrats is the
fact that it reinstated the Children's
Health Insurance Program Nora for
another six years both important points
Nancy thank you so much